hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the world's quietest
let's play I thought that myself when I
was meditating this morning what better
way to test out the capabilities of this
new room than with another world's
quietest let's play through the air for
power so let's get started
oh look it's another big ball throw not
as big and I like em big you sack of
crap but the chances of you getting the
correct spot are very slim no you bag of
tits you son of a [ __ ] how dare you
mash my face if I have to do this
[ __ ] again I'll tear off your entire
ass and then feed it to yourself ah the
center square the possibilities for
victory are endless and you have just
[ __ ] yourself watch and weep
victory is assured there's no way that I
can [ __ ] this up I am the greatest ever
exist come along little Johnny it has
been a while I hope you don't mind the
bumpy ride that we're going upon Johnny
come back here you little [ __ ] once more
under the bridge Rupp held by who I
thought was once my friend Wow
it seems I've found the secret to suck
come with mommy little children little
Johnny stay there it's okay goodbye
Susan Susan made the right call huh well
I suppose this is better than actually
trying now
little Johnny if you could just I did
not go that was not me I take great
offense to this and I believe you oh
well never mind thank you if you could
stop ruining my butthole what did I just
say ooh five balls
it seems my medical condition has
worsened by a factor of 2.5 I don't like
that no no no no no
my vengeance will be endless you will
see [ __ ] on you sack oh [ __ ] I want to
catch it I caught it
no I'll catch it
yeah it's it's candy the same way
ah you bastard
kiddies when I get out of this ball
work doesn't work whisperer social
Johnny you will not mock you
little Johnny what if you're done to
become immune to my Swartz missiles only
if you dodge this next one I will
officially stop hating on you little
Johnny have a nice day lady are you
flirting with me with the phone up your
butt because I don't take kindly to that
I'm pretty sure this was not part of my
contract and frankly I hate everything
you stand for